[Musique]
Hélène Alec bonsoir
bonsoir alors victoire décisive vient
dans une élection partielle vous allez
me dire mais victoire on va voir le
résultat Charles Souchon qui était lui
ancien ministre des Finances ontariens
51% des voiles conservateurs
et arrivent avec 33
37 par delémé pour cent des voies je
fais entendre tout de suite pierre
Paulus chacun a demandé mais ça aurait
dû vous ce que vous auriez dû faire
mieux et Monsieur Trudeau qui parle de
ça c'est très rapide on revient
lorsqu'on avait gagné le gouvernement
majoritaire mais il reste actuellement
moi ce que je vois surtout c'est le taux
de participation qui était très faible
on peut pas le prendre comme un échec
compte tenu que c'est un comté qui est
libéral de
façon assez coutumière
la réalité c'est des partiels c'est
important c'est un moment pour les
citoyens de choisir une voie forte pour
leur communauté mais aussi de se pencher
sur les enjeux de qui qui tiennent au
coeur les citoyens et le gouvernement
fédéral
Hélène vous étiez là aussi je le disais
à Madeleine la soirée où monsieur
poirievre est arrivé avec l'image d'un
d'un batailleur de quelqu'un qui allait
faire à chaque fois des luttes serrées
enfin on a eu l'impression qu'ils ont
peut-être jeté la serviette un peu trop
tôt ai-je raison Hélène est-ce que c'est
une défaite importante pour les
conservateurs mais c'est sûr que ils
sont tristes mais il faut remettre les
choses en perspective voici une
circonscription de la banlieue
torontoise comme le disait monsieur
Paulus c'est une circonscription que
dans les dernières années les
conservateurs n'ont gagné qu'une seule
fois lorsqu'ils ont gagné leur majorité
de 2011 avec monsieur Harper alors c'est
genre de circonscription qui peut
basculer quand ça va bien pour les
conservateurs mais autrement qui est
libéré alors c'est pour ça qu'on la
voyait un peu comme un baromètre mais
quand même il faut garder à l'esprit que
les conservateurs ont déjà réussi à
former le gouvernement sans être
majoritaire et donc sans avoir ce genre
de circonscription là
moi je remarque quand même qu'à
37%, ils sont demeuré à peu près stables
par rapport aux résultats obtenus à la
générale de l'année dernière donc samedi
quoi que bon il y a peut-être pas
d'engouement pour Pierre pollièvre en ce
moment dans ce genre de circonscription
là mais il y a pas de des aveux non plus
on voit les chiffres dont vous faites
référence moins à 1% pour les
conservateurs plus 6 pour les libéraux
qui ont pas mal gruger le vote du NPD
exactement et puis vous dites bon est-ce
qu'ils ont jeté la serviette moi ce que
je vois beaucoup de la part de Monsieur
Poirier parce qu'on le voit pas beaucoup
il se prononce sur très peu de choses
certainement pas sur les enjeux de leur
il se tient quand même en retrait
beaucoup de plusieurs débats politiques
et moi je pense qu'il poursuit ce qu'on
appelle lorsqu'on pourrait appeler la
stratégie de l'effacement il a eu une
campagne au leadership non mais je pense
que c'est très c'est très contrôlé c'est
très voulu comme ça il a une campagne au
leadership assez tonitruante il a fait
parler de lui pas toujours pour les
bonnes raisons vous parlez des Bitcoin
aujourd'hui c'est certainement pas
quelque chose qui est à son actif mais
plutôt à son passif et là je pense que
les conservateurs se disent laissons le
libérer les libéraux s'enfoncer
eux-mêmes avec la crise économique
l'inflation ou les taux d'intérêt il
sera toujours temps de remonter de
revenir de faire parler de nous quand on
s'approchera de l'échéance électorale ok
politique de retrait donc
[Musique]
en même temps avec troisième mandat
libéral en pleine crise inflationniste
nouveau chef qui arrive bagarreur on
aurait pu s'attendre aussi parce que
s'ils veulent être majoritaire un jour
ces gens de sa construction qui vont
devoir gagner Alec quand même qu'est-ce
que vous lisez là-dedans
moi je suis moins indulgent Hélène je
pense que Pierre poliev s'il veut
remporter un gouvernement majoritaire
jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est son
objectif non pas d'être minoritaire mais
majoritaire il doit remporter des
circonscriptions comme ici sauvegarde
dans les banlieues de Toronto ce genre
de séquences dont il a besoin Philippe
gif Fournier fait toujours la liste sur
son site 338 Canada a mis collaborateur
le spécialiste des sondages des
projections où les quels sont les
circonscriptions ou les chacune des
parties le plus de chances de l'emporter
les 150 4e sur la liste donc c'est pas
compter facile pour les conservateurs
mais c'est en bas de la des 170 requis
pour former un gouvernement majoritaire
là c'est pas le trans 330e il est 154e
hausse du coût de la vie inflation
problème dans les urgences on parle
beaucoup de transferts en santé
gouvernement usé puis employé vient
d'arriver devrait avoir au moins fait le
même score que 2021 ou stairway autour
qui a été là et qui a pas remporté la
circonscription on a fait moins c'est
vrai que moins de participation il y
avait un candidat vedette chez les
libéra mais si on remporte pas des
messages on va les remporter où les
circonscriptions pour former la majorité
moi je trouve qu'il y a un voyant jaune
qui clignote sur le tableau de bord de
Pierre polieve pas certains que la
stratégie d'effacement dont parlait
laine est très payante
et vous-même mais je crois vous avez dit
waouh puis enfin beaucoup de gens ont
été impressionnés par la combativité de
cet homme qu'on a tous dit ce soir-là oh
Justin Trudeau a devant lui quelqu'un
qui a envie de bagarrer piquer capable
d'envoyer or il y a quasiment pas été
faire campagne
non bébé et c'est vrai en tout on ne le
voit pas c'est pas juste qui parle pas à
la presse parlementaire c'est que de
manière générale il ne saisit pas les
grands dossiers mais vous savez vous
savez cette phrase un peu étrange là que
les conservateurs ont utilisé beaucoup à
la Chambre triplés triplés tripler la
taxe sur le carbone un peu bizarre là il
répète ça constamment et un moment donné
je parlais avec des conservateurs loin
des micros mais c'est quoi cette affaire
là ça marche pas ça s'accroche pas
autant que votre justinflation par
exemple oui mais pendant qu'on fait ça
puis que vous vous posez toutes des
questions sur de quoi c'est que ça veut
dire ben vous oubliez les bit et donc il
semblait avoir cette idée de l'époteur
vous dites
il va sortir pour mieux bondir ok très
bien Marie qui peut être se regagne
avoir est-ce que c'est sérieux on va
aller vite on va écouter monsieur signe
est-ce que c'est sérieux il l'a dit hier
mais là écoutez les crises Insurgentes
c'est peut-être de nature à me faire
douter de mon appui envers le
gouvernement minoritaire de Monsieur
Trudeau en écoute
je veux que ça fonctionne donc mon but
n'est pas de déclencher une action mais
bon maintenant c'est fort parce que je
veux voir des actions donc si le
gouvernement n'agit pas si c'est clair
tu nous effores que le goût ne veut pas
dire ce qu'il faut pour aider les gens
on a le pouvoir de retirer notre vie
quand on sort du cercle de terroir on a
un peu l'impression qu'il dit j'existe
aussi je vous rappelle que j'existe et
que je pourrais hypothétiquement faire
tomber ce gouvernement Alec
ouais je pense qu'on est plus près d'un
créditaire que d'une menace réelle il y
a pas personne que le goût d'aller en
élection en début de 2023 y compris le
NPD vous venez de voir les résultats
dans Mr nous ont perdu 5 points par
rapport à la dernière fois donc c'est
pas un contexte et ça nécessairement
favorable pour eux non plus le NPD
essaie de s'accrocher à des dossiers qui
touchent les gens ils ont parlé beaucoup
de la vie inflation les conservateurs
sont sur le même terrain sur la santé
ils essaient d'être plus visible que les
autres partis politiques en disant ben
ça prend les transferts en santé il faut
que je fasse une offre sa part on joue
dans le film des provinces qui veulent
beaucoup de transferts en santé donc on
essaie d'attirer l'attention quand on
dit il faut que je t'aide rideau règle
les problèmes dans les urgences
pédiatriques au pays ils ont il y a une
marche le confranchit c'est pas comme si
Justin Trudeau grêle système de santé
puis qui pouvait régler ce problème là
donc on exagère peut-être un peu mais ça
va mettre la pression sur juste un truc
d'eau qui je pense ne pourra pas arriver
au budget du mois de mars avec Christian
freelin sans avoir une hausse des
transferts en santé il devrait se passer
quelque chose dans les trois premiers
mois de l'année et le NPD ajoute sa voix
je pense pour mettre la pression
mais je ne crois pas à des élections en
lien avec ce dossier là cette pression
mais pas de menace réelle Hélène oui je
suis absolument d'accord avec Alex
là-dessus et en fait rappelez-vous que
c'est pas la première fois on est rendu
au deuxième
ultimatum cet automne en septembre
dernier Monsieur sign nous avait dit
essentiellement
mais à sa décharge le premier ultimatum
c'était de dire si d'ici la fin de
l'année je n'obtiens pas une assurance
dentaire et bien je pourrais retirer mon
appui il l'a reçu cette assurance
dentaire bon certains pourraient
chipoter là c'est pas vraiment un
programme d'assurance c'est plus un
programme de chèque mais néanmoins ça a
été mis en place donc il a obtenu mais
bref je suis totalement d'accord avec
Alec c'est beaucoup plus une façon de
dire j'existe et effectivement comme
avec le mentionné il faut y voir aussi
aller regarder les résultats s'asseoir
quand le NPD par 5 points pourcentage
alors qu'il n'en est en avait eu 10 à la
dernière élection il y a perdu
essentiellement la moitié de ses appuis
oui c'est une partiel prononcée avec des
pincettes mais néanmoins
à démontrer c'est ce qu'on dit souvent
c'est que dans ce genre d'alliance c'est
souvent le parti qui forme le pouvoir
dans ce que si les libéraux qui en
tirent les bénéfices alors que le parti
qui l'appuit dans ce cas-ci le NPD se
fait un peu oublier et souvent à
l'élection d'après en paie le prix s'il
y a un message à tirer de l'élection
partielle d'hier moi je le verrai
surtout de ce côté-là que ça sera pas
payant pour le NPD à la prochaine
génération monsieur Trudeau a commencé
cette série d'entrevues de fin d'année
et à la presque canadienne il dit le
Québec on va pouvoir lire l'extrait le
Québec va pouvoir accueillir pourrait
accueillir 112 immigrants par année la
pleine capacité à la pleine capacité
c'est un de stage je ne suis pas en
train de recommander ça non plus réponse
de la ministre
québécoises au Québec et au Québec seul
de déterminer ses seuils d'immigration
le Québec un double défi qui est unique
au Canada etc je veux entendre monsieur
Trudeau qui a à l'entrée de la période
des questions à dire parce qu'on lui a
demandé vous voulez que le Québec
accueille 112 mais les migrants réponse
j'ai souligné que le Québec a la
capacité de choisir ses feuilles
d'immigration la capacité de les
augmenter ici veulent mais c'est leur
décision
on me dit dans l'oreille on va revenir à
ça on me dit dans l'oreille je veux vous
le dire madame monsieur parce qu'on en a
beaucoup parlé en début d'émission la
petite fillette de 7 ans sur Parthenay
qui a été frappé par une automobiliste
qui s'est enfui et décédé ça a été
annoncé par
par la police donc malheureusement le
pire est arrivé dans ce cas-là on
parlait à la responsable Ville de
Montréal sur la sécurité partenaire et
voisins disent c'est devenu une
autoroute alors voilà je referme ça mais
je voulais le dire aux gens parce que ça
vient d'arriver
monsieur Trudeau
est-ce qu'une est-ce que inévitablement
se débat ne va pas être relancé il y a
une rencontre Trudeau le goût vendredi
matin Hélène
oui sûrement en même temps monsieur
Trudeau il dit pas fait ça mais il
encourage à faire ça dans l'extrait il y
avait enfin je sais pas c'est le même
extrait mais il y a bien dit après ce
canadienne je pense au Québec devrait
songer à hausser ses cibles et en fait
c'est pas la première fois le kotawa dit
ça monsieur Trudeau avait dit début
octobre je pense que Québec devrait
songer à hausser pour suivre un peu la
cadence fédérale et il y avait Pablo
Rodriguez qui avait dit vous pouvez
aller jusqu'à dans les six chiffres et
vous n'avez qu'à sélectionner des
francophones et voilà et tout sera réglé
alors on est dans cette logique les
libéraux à Ottawa veulent augmenter
le nombre d'immigrants total ils ne
veulent pas se faire accuser de de
l'odieux de diluer le fait français au
Québec et donc il jette la balle dans le
cadre québécois en disant à vous de
choisir des francophones et il y en a
pas de problème le problème il est dans
votre tête essentiellement
étant donné que tirer des francophones
ça a l'air tellement facile faudrait
leur demander pourquoi il rate leur
cible l'année après année depuis 20 ans
vers l'immigration francophone c'est un
objectif là mais c'est pas
nécessairement facile à atteindre leur
112000 francophones par année c'est la
marche c'est très haute est-ce que le
Québec a la capacité de le faire
techniquement oui ce qu'il a la volonté
de le faire politiquement non parce que
quand je dis techniquement oui parce
qu'il a l'entente pour le faire avec
Ottawa il a aussi sur son territoire
beaucoup plus que 50 000 nouveaux
arrivants par année pour l'année 2021
lorsqu'on inclut les travailleurs
étrangers temporaires les étudiants
également on est à 167.000 étrangers qui
sont en seul Québécois on pourrait très
bien donner donc le certificat de
sélection du Québec évidemment la
résidence permanente et la citoyenneté à
112000 personnes le problème c'est que
il faut aussi être capable à un moment
donné de les sélectionner pour leur
langue il y a beaucoup de travailleurs
étrangers temporaires beaucoup
d'étudiants étrangers d'étrangers qui ne
parlent pas français beaucoup plus que
dans le bassin qu'on sélectionne de
manière permanente donc avant d'être
capable de renforcer la connaissance du
français des travailleurs étrangers
temporaires d'accueillir Dav
antage pour seulement mes guilds pas
seulement Concordia ou Bishop mais
d'avoir plus de francophones ça va
prendre quand même un virage qui peut
prendre un angle qui peut prendre deux
ans avant d'être capable peut-être
éventuellement d'augmenter les seuils
pas à 112000 mais un 55 un 60 65 mais
faut revoir la façon dont sélectionne
les immigrants francophones ça ça sera
pas la première année un petit mot en
terminant sur cette rencontre j'en
parlais hier rapidement Hélène comment
vous voyez comment elle s'inscrit dans
quel climat entre monsieur Legault et
Monsieur Trudeau vendredi matin santé et
migration ça va être les deux gros
sujets évidemment oui puis sur
immigration aussi ben écoutez monsieur
Trudeau clairement
veut rencontrer ces homologues un à un
plutôt qu'en groupe il ne veut pas être
repris dans les vieux films qu'on
suivait rappelez-vous Patrice avec ces
grandes messes avec jean-chrétiens qui
faisaient face à la trace Premier
ministre qui lui réclamait plus d'argent
encore aujourd'hui monsieur Trudeau le
dit pas de chèque en blanc pour les
provinces alors on est dans cette
optique là qui va lui qui vont lui dire
bah oui ok peut-être plus d'argent mais
il faut répondre à un certain nombre de
conditions je suis pas certaine que
monsieur Legault va sortir de cette
rencontre satisfait d'avoir obtenu
quelconque gain il semble y avoir une
certaine rigidité de part et d'autre là
en matière notamment de santé mais aussi
l'immigration je vois pas beaucoup de
rapprochement mais tout ça risque de
rester très cordial mais
ce qui est simple peut-être avec en
terminant c'est qu'il y a pas d'échéance
électorale à très très propre donc ça
permet peut-être de travailler les
dossiers plus
quoi avec plus
profondeur on a moins besoin de bomber
le torse de côté comme de l'autre puis
de jouer du muscle un peu et dans les
deux cas autant santé que l'immigration
qui vont être les deux gros sujets je
pense qui vont être abordés on va voir
un besoin de montrer des résultats
autant à Québec à Ottawa parce que la
population va commencer à s'impatienter
donc je pense qu'on a davantage besoin
de s'entendre que de désaccord mais
comme le dilemme ça va pas se régler
vendredi mais peut-être en fait la table
pour les premiers mois de 2022 merci
beaucoup à vous deux merci bonne soirée
et Mesdames et Messieurs après la pause
je vais vous faire le bilan de cette
triste nouvelle on a davantage de
détails sur cette sur ce thème qui
aurait happé donc une thérapie une jeune
fille de 7 ans à tout de suite pour voir
nos émissions en entier rendez-vous sur
la chaîne ici RDI